you know our next guest jonathan van
nessas the member of the fab five on the
emmy award-winning queer eye it's known
for helping people look and feel good
come on you know the show jonathan is
also a new york times bestselling author
comedian and hair stylist and now
they're launching a brand new show on
netflix called getting curious with
jonathan van ness on the show jonathan
shows his curiosity by exploring all
types of new things from eating bugs to
scaling skyscrapers and even learning
how to ice skate take a look
i love my curves i love my swerves but
to hoist
all 11 inches off the ice to do those
one and a half rotations takes some
strength do we want to just go for an
accident yeah should i yeah am i gonna
kill you no you're gonna be good okay
i've never done a single axle before
but i'm gonna do one
okay
peel city fairy heel city
joins us right now good morning jonathan
how are you doing i'm great should i ask
how are you feeling because i'm i'm all
good my hip survives that falls is the
guy with the big fishing rod supposed to
keep you up that's part of the plot
twist you'll see that in there i thought
i was gonna i thought i could really go
for it uh but it turns out you can in
fact fall
on the spot three or four times yeah i
did all right so this show is a spin-off
of your popular podcast of the same name
so what drew you to turn your podcast
into a series i think you know being my
first solo series and you know executive
producing this series i wanted to do
something that felt like a little
familiar to me i've been doing getting
curious a podcast for six years but
obviously taking it to tv i wanted to
have a world that i felt a little like
comfortable to explore and make it
different and in the podcast i interview
one person in the tv show i interview
like three four or five experts per show
so it's the tv show is definitely like
quicker paced it's a little more fast
it's uh more layers um
it's more like a surface on each topic
as opposed to such a deep dive where the
podcast is like an hour of like lots of
chatting this is like we're giving you
action we're giving you comedy we're
giving you adventure honey it's got to
be a dream job honey
because jonathan honestly you get to do
whatever
you want to do in terms of what are you
curious about right and it can go from a
to z yep which i think just gives you
incredible freedom it really does so you
you talk about ice skating you've loved
that as a kid you've talked about bugs
you like that as a kid you have a great
segment on hair
fears conquering fears politics gender
yeah yes yeah we did a lot why was it
important to step outside your comfort
zone right well i always say i think
it's like it's a little bit of a cliche
but i definitely think it's true we
don't grow when we're totally
comfortable i think we grow the most we
experience the most when we get out of
our comfort zone so i did want to take a
lot of those i call them like hard
rights uh you think you're going over
here but yeah we're going to the right
so i did want to do that i wanted to
challenge myself in this series um
slight correction gail i did not like
bugs as a child i've always hated them i
was very scared but then i moved to
texas learned that bugs are kind of
interesting or are they are they no no
gorgeous or gross oh here we go
is that a tarantula yeah it's a ch
that's my hand that's not even fake for
tv like that is not a hand double that
is my hand i almost passed out but
actually that bug expert he's kind of
like a brawny retired like fireman yes
so he was giving i felt like there was
like zaddy vibes so i could relax
but it's you were so entertaining i was
safe i was thinking you know what
jonathan you know what's so great my
favorite episode i have to say was
bye-bye to binary it was it really was
because i think it's really i thought it
was smart very well done very well done
and i know you want to educate but you
said we need to get past that you said
as a little kid you knew at a very early
age you didn't feel male and you didn't
feel female but you felt alone and what
you know is you're not alone right and
that actually there is just so many
people in the non-binary gender
non-conforming trans community that is
so timeless um i think so often now we
think that this is like a very new
phenomenon when in reality people like
me um people in in my community have
been existing for thousands and
thousands of years and what is more new
is our kind of modern interpretation of
the gender binary and so i wanted to
explore that um i wanted to explore it
in a way that can still be funny and
inclusive and it's not um
i'm not finger-pointing at you we're
really just exploring and having a good
time and also to that uh sense i think
in every question in the series yeah i
tried to take like a how did we get here
yes what's going on now and what are we
gonna do later uh it's kind of like the
christmas story vibes you know past
present future on all of these questions
to kind of give us a more like
full-bodied approach and answer to the
questions that i'm asking education
awareness but you know what yes even
getting ready for this segment the
producer's saying and they like to ice
skate and they like to and then they
went to and they got married and i said
who else is coming besides jonathan and
they go no it's just jonathan i mean i
think we all have to readjust our
thinking and it's not on us
i mean it's not on you to make sure that
we get it right well i mean i think
we're all on this like exploration of
learning i think that um it's
we're all in an
exploration of learning and so i think
that obviously this in this year in the
last few years we've seen a consistent
uptick in violence against trans people
violence against gender non-conforming
people so i think any area where i can
bring humanity into a lived experience
that i've gone through um i want to do
that because ultimately we're all human
we all want to be loved we all want to
be in a community that accepts us and so
i wanted to kind of bring that uh to the
to the screen in that episode we should
say it's funny too
you know you do some serious stuff
because you said you can do both at the
same time yeah it can be challenging but
it can also be delightful yeah exactly
can i ask a non-work question yes uh
okay in your spare time you do
gymnastics i do
i do why would you love it well you know
what it was i was a cheerleader growing
up and then i became a stand-up comedian
you're a cheerleader i was a cheerleader
growing up give us a cheer give us a
chance um go blue let's fight go white
win tonight yes our colors are blue and
white in high school blue devils um i
can hear kathy dooley cheering me on
right now but that's a good form right
there thank you oh yeah look at that oh
my birani i had to fight for that ending
but i did it but yeah i once a year when
you're a former cheerleader usually what
happens is it's usually outside of a bar
on concrete very not very dangerous and
you do your once annual can i still do a
backhand spring thing well in 2019 when
i did that i had so happened to be on
stage doing comedy and then that's when
i realized
you have like a whole audience like just
do a gymnastics routine so then i
started doing gymnastics like seriously
again because now i do like a spoof
routine that's an actual routine and my
stand-up comedy shows it's really funny
the uh the guy with the big fishing rod
that keeps you on your feet would be
helpful outside of bars sometimes yeah
he would you know
he could be a really good spot for
gymnastics too
you have a huge cheer squad gizelle
who's in our studio when you walk in she
goes i love him i go what do you love
about him she says everything everything
love you too just that loud we
appreciate it gizelle real quick what do
you want people to take away from the
show i want them to take comedy um
learning um just a good time it's also
something that's really good for all
ages your whole family you can watch it
um i really just want people to take fun
and uh curiosity mission accomplished
john thank you thanks for having me look
at fierce today thank you all right
jonathan van ness thank you so much
curious with jonathan venice is
available on netflix starting friday